or anything but I'm saying you can take
the role seriously without taking
yourself too seriously Ronald Reagan was
excellent using self-deprecating humor
making himself the butt of the joke
didn't take himself too seriously and
that allowed people around him to relax
and if the people around him were
relaxed they'd bring their best workout
I was not terrified that the guillotine
was gonna fall at any moment working for
this man he surrounded us with such an
era of acceptance and appreciation and a
sense of humor about things because not
everything went perfectly sometimes
things actually went wrong even for the
president and when you were part of that
regardless of how hard you had tried to
make everything perfect sometimes things
just didn't go as planned and he was
always gracious to roll with that to
have a sense of humor
and so then as somebody who works for a
man like that you're not afraid to try
something new to put yourself out there
a little bit to maybe take a chance
because you know that he'll he's got
your back he's gonna live life with a
sense of humor he was a man of
incredible respect whether it was
presidents that had come before him or
presidents that had come after him what
he also had a great respect for women he
talks about his mother as being the most
important person in his early life of
course there's so much has been written
about his relationship with mrs. Reagan
and the respect that they had with each
other for each other mother Teresa came
in to visit the office and this little
tiny woman who he recognized as being a
giant on the world stage he had amazing
respect for and of course being the
first president to put a woman on the
Supreme Court with the appointment of
Sandra Day O'Connor that was something
he was very proud of they respected
women he respected their role and this
was many many years ago so that wasn't
even one of our big issues back then but
it was important to him to show respect
as a young woman working for him I
always felt his utmost respect toward me
and his appreciation for the value that
I added he was a man of incredible
patriotism and of course that's
something you would expect from a
but I can tell you from having been
behind the scenes with him all the time
that was not something he just did when
the cameras were rolling so this man was
patriotic to the core how many times do
you think he's heard the star-spangled
banner the national anthem or any of
these other songs being played when we
would have guests come to the office a
lot of times they would perform for them
they would sing for him or play for
music for him and you can imagine if
you're coming to perform for the
president what is what is what are you
gonna probably perform probably going to
play patriotic music right so here's
this man you know he's heard these songs
a thousand times before and yet I would
watch him and as the song would start
you'd see him kind of tapping his toe in
time singing along every word to every
verse verses I didn't even know existed
he knew every word and every now and
then you would see him and he would
stand up just at attention out of
respect
I'll put his hand over his heart are
there certain songs that were just so
beautifully performed you would look
over and actually see tears misting up
in his eyes this is a man who was
patriotic to his core he loved this
country it meant something to him he
felt the honor and the privilege of
having served at the highest level of
this country he was proud for what he
had been able to represent and proud of
what America represented on the world
stage he also used to joke with mrs.
Reagan that he hoped it was okay with
her but there was another woman in his
life and he would always talk about Lady
Liberty as being the other woman in his
life which I thought was especially
sweet and he would describe Lady Liberty
as being this beautiful feminine lady
who was the beacon of freedom for the
world he was a man of incredible
patriotism he also was a man of extreme
gratitude think of all the things people
did for the president all the time he
was aware he was appreciative here he is
getting the Presidential Medal of
Freedom in the White House from his
successor George Bush who was president
at the time we went to the White House
he presented him with the Medal of
Freedom here's a man who's won every
award gotten every trophy every
certificate right
so on the way home what does he do takes
off his jacket it's a long six-hour
flight home
he left his medal on he wore that medal
all the way home it meant something to
him it was a very special what it
represented and the people it meant that
he had represented he appreciated that
so much he wore it all the way home now
another thing I noticed about this photo
that I didn't notice when I first took
it what is he doing in this photo can
you tell he's got his pen out and his
note card he's writing his thank-you
notes anybody else a big note writer out
here I am definitely because of this man
if he can do it I can do here we had
just received the Presidential Medal of
Freedom and by the way he was fairly
elderly at this time he's not taking a
nap he's not you know having a champagne
party he's not saying I'm going to
Disneyland
what's he doing he's writing his
thank-you notes on the plane on the way
home by the way he had an executive
assistant who would have been more than
happy to do that for him I was part of
what I did was a lot of his
correspondence but instead he's putting
pen to paper right then saying what he
wants to say expressing his gratitude
right after the moment so because of
this photo every time I travel quite a
bit every time I get on the plane I
carry my little note cards with me and I
think if this man can do it I can do it
usually before the plane even takes off
I pull out my note cards right my little
thank-yous for the trip he's a great
example of gratitude as he was at the
highest and the best level and if he can
be grateful we all can be one of my
favorite treasures that I have from my
years of working for him is this my
daughter's actually I am a son and three
daughters
they were looking through my jewelry box
the other day trying to find something
to steal of mine you know I guess that's
a compliment when your kids want to
steal your stuff but yeah they were
rummaging through looking for something
good well they came across this green
leather box mom what is this it had this
big gold seal something on it and mom
what is this I said I I don't know I
remember it but let me
I pulled up a little card it was a gold
watch that had been given to me by the
king of Jordan who knew tucked away in
my jewelry box so I got a lot of amazing
gifts over the years the gold watch a
jort from the king of Jordan no means
nothing to me compared to this little
piece of paper and when it represents
Ronald Reagan took pen to paper to show
his gratitude to me and this means more
to me than anything in the world why
because it's from his heart it was from
him personally he gave this to me for
Christmas it says Merry Christmas to
Peggy Nancy and Ronald Reagan and when
he gave it to me he was almost a little
apologetic he said Peggy I made this for
you for Christmas and I hope you'll like
it and he said but I really wanted to do
something more but you always do all my
shopping so I wasn't sure exactly how to
manage that and this was before Amazon
couldn't have a drone delivery nothing
like that
so he had very creatively come up with a
way to show his gratitude toward me and
there's nothing I treasure in the world
more than this because of what it
symbolizes the world knew him for so
many things I knew him as a man of
incredible kindness he was there this
does look like a prom picture but he
actually was celebrating with me I told
him I had just gotten engaged to my
husband Greg we have our 27th wedding
anniversary coming up in a few weeks
which makes me sound really old
I actually got married for the I got
married and had three of my four
children while I was working for the
president so you can imagine those were
some crazy busy years but the president
was wonderful as was mrs. Reagan to
welcome all these changing family
dynamics they were there to welcome my
first my son Taylor in my second my
daughter Courtney and my third my
daughter Paige and my fourth my daughter
Jocelyn
at which point mrs. Reagan one day
pulled me out into the hallway and she
said Peggy you know how this is
happening right
not really a conversation I want to have
with the former first lady but yes for
and no more so the family was complete
but it was great over the years to be
able to interact with the Reagan's
casually up at their house there was
nothing like looking over at Ronald
Reagan pushing my son's stroller through
the LA Zoo flanked by United States
Secret Service swimming in the pool
celebrating birthdays and Halloween and
Christmas together let's see and for my
kids they grew up thinking this was all
very normal
my son would look at me in the evening
and I've got a black tie dress on and he
would look at me and say mommy are
you're having dinner tonight with Daddy
or the president and then when the
office kids would get together they
would say okay you beat the first lady
you be Secret Service and they talked to
their sleeve and peek around and hands
under the coat and all of that it was
just very normal to them and I always
appreciated the Reagan's allowing my
family to grow up alongside them so my
husband got into the action as well and
he was very fortunate that as President
Reagan's friends got older a lot of them
didn't really golf anymore and Ronald
Reagan love to golf although I will say
he only golf to eight times while he was
president but he did go about a couple
of times a month post presidency and
always enjoyed it but his friends were
getting older a lot of them had back
trouble or had gone to the desert
weren't available and so every now and
then on a Friday afternoon mrs. Reagan
would call the house and she'd asked for
Greg and she would say Greg you know
Ronnie really needs a fourth tomorrow
is there any way you could go out and
play so he of course would say yes and
then he would turn to me and he'd say
Peggy I really was looking forward to
mowing the lawn tomorrow and I couldn't
wait to tackle that honeydew list of to
do chores but duty calls
I must serve my country I must play golf
with the president so I'd say okay let
me get this straight so I work hard all
week long and then you go golf on
Saturdays yeah that's about right
so Greg came back with lots of great
stories from the golf course and enjoyed
again that behind-the-scenes time with
the president oops and really in so many
ways I feel like I grew up with Ronald
Reagan he taught me everything I will
to know about how to weed and how to
live not by a list of rules or lessons
but just by how he lived his life so
when you look at this list diplomacy
authenticity humble beginnings optimism
humility humor respect patriotism
gratitude and kindness does that
surprise you that that would be the
recipe for success Ronald Reagan's way
it certainly is not the type of
leadership we see depicted on TV or in
the movies right but I can tell you this
man had a spine of Steel
he went toe-to-toe with the Communists
and the communists and brought down the
Soviet Union in a lot of ways but he
also had a beautiful humanity behind him
and so as you're thinking about your own
leadership moving forward realize that
you can be tough you can accomplish
everything you want to you can be very
hard-working very driven but you can
also incorporate these beautiful
elements which Ronald Reagan embodied
one of the things that I kind of took
away from my entire experience with him
is that your legacy is not something
that's really written after you're gone
but it's something that you write with
every single day of your life and so I
challenge you to lead and live as if
your legacy depends on it because it
does every single day you were writing
your legacy Ronald Reagan's legacy
wasn't written after he left us he had
already written his legacy with every
day of his life
I saw it behind the scenes the legacy he
left in me I saw it every day when we
walked out of the office seeing how the
world responded to him seeing how he
responded to the world that was his
legacy on display your legacy has
already started you're already living it
and if your legacy right now is not what
you want people to be telling about you
when you're gone then now's the time to
change that it's never too late to pivot
to head into a better direction because
your legacy is already started it's
already going his legacy of course now
we remember in an entirely different way
now that he's gone but even after he
passed away we pictured lines
hours and hours people waiting just to
walk past his flag-draped casket these
were people that most likely had never
even met Ronald Reagan they didn't know
him personally and yet they had an
attachment to him they had a fondness
for him and I would say it's because
they knew that he always cared about
them and so they always had cared about
him people lined the streets and waited
for hours just to watch him drive by one
last moment to touch and interact with
this man's life his legacy is lasting
and is so memorable and not for all the
policies and not for all the elements of
the presidency although we talk about
those two but for the character the man
how you read how you live that equals
your legacy so Ronald Reagan's passing
of course made us cry but in his
lifetime he often made us laugh and I
believe that part of the reason we still
miss him today is because we miss how we
felt as a nation under Ronald Reagan we
miss how we felt when we were prospering
economically what we were proud
diplomatically when we're strong
militarily and bold and shining the
torch of freedom to every corner of the
globe where oppression still existed I
believe that now more than ever we as a
nation don't want to get over Ronald
Reagan and his impact on our nation but
we want to get back to him and we want
to get back to what are you represented
and we want to get back to loving
ourselves and loving America as we did
when Ronald Reagan was president the
Great Communicator always said it best
and so I want to read you a quote it's
one of my favorites and I think
especially for this time frame now when
everything in politics everything in
society is so divisive Ronald Reagan
always had a great way of bringing
people together reminding us what is
important in reminding us that there's
always a better way in 1982 his
convention speech in Houston he said and
whatever else history may say about me
when I'm gone I hope it will record that
I appealed to your best hopes not to
your worst fears to your confidence
rather than your doubts my dream is that
you will travel the road
ahead with Liberty's lamp guiding your
steps and opportunities armed steadying
your way we'd hear a lot of fear and
doubt don't we how wonderful to be
reminded that we can lead by appealing
to confidence and two best hopes he also
said my fondest hope is for each of you
and especially the young people here and
I loved it he used to always think about
the future about the young people and
actually before Donald Trump he was the
oldest president that had ever served
but was always forward-looking always
thinking about the future and young
people
so he says especially for the young
people here is that you will love your
country not for her power or her wealth
but for her selflessness and her
idealism may each of you have the heart
to conceive the understanding to direct
and the hand to execute works that will
make the world a little better for your
having been here and I have no doubt
that through this program and all the
things that each one of you are doing in
your own little corners of the world
that you definitely are making this
world a better place where your having
been here so I think Liam was going to
come up on we're gonna do some questions
and so thank you very much
thank you so much for that talk I think
that was really really inspiring for all
of us to hear those of us who have been
here for a while but also those of us
who maybe joined just last year that's
such a awesome story to hearing it to
learn a little bit more about the
president so to start with I would like
to go back towards a little bit whoops
towards where things kind of all started
so you were said in the book you know
that your life and that and the course
that it would take was forever changed
by the phone call that you got from the
office of Ronald Reagan
so you mentioned like writing letters to
like different organizations asking for
the opportunity to intern with them and
several weeks later came that phone call
so what would you think that was in that
letter that made them consider who as
you said could work for President Reagan
even though you had no political work
experience at that time yeah yeah so I
was kind of a nerdy little kid I loved
government and politics I don't know was
just this alternate reality of me that I
was so fascinated with and I guess if
you grow up in the Beltway of Washington
DC that would be fairly common when I
grew up in Southern California down in
Orange County
back in the day really when women in
general weren't even involved in
politics and so I didn't have any role
model or example or even know that women
could be involved in politics but it was
just fascinated by the whole idea of the
presidency so fast forward into college
I'm a communications major the great
communicators on the White House and
he's the perfect convergence of
everything I love he's a gentlemanly man
of faith he's a communicator
he was a president I mean everything all
together right there so I was raised by
a dad who said somebody has got to have
the job we want and it might as well be
you so I grew up believing that and
believing that anything was possible so
when Ronald Reagan left the White House
came back to LA I thought if I could
work for anybody in the world that's who
I would work for and somebody's got to
have that job right so I wrote a letter
to the office was brought in for an
interview was terrified but at the same
time I had a feeling that that was all
these little pieces of my life had
really led up to that point and you know
a lot of people will say oh you were so
lucky I believe that luck has some
things to do in life we could call it
Providence or God's divine blessing but
I think a lot of people have luck in
life and they are not willing to
recognize it they're not ready to grab
it when it comes and they certainly
aren't willing to put in the work to
maximize it and so I was very fortunate
to have the opportunity that I did but I
believe that everybody is fortunate and
we have a lot of luck in your life if
you're ready to grab it so and actually
we noticed that quote that you had from
your father where you know he said
someone has the job you want so you
might as well be used so what advice do
you think that you would give your
children as you feel for them that you
tried to give them that you would hope
that they would hold on to yeah
so I have four children and there
probably is different as four humans can
be which I loved so I figured they they
were already equipped with certain
skills and traits and talents that were
embedded in them when they were born and
so as a mom I feel like it's my role to
nurture and water and facilitate them
growing into what they were meant to be
and never make them into what I want
them to be and for my children I want
them to know that anything is possible
and especially for my daughters my
mother was an incredible mother and
Betty Crocker stay-at-home wonderful
well-educated woman who chose to be home
and raise her family and I always
appreciate it and admired that I
actually thought I would never be a
working mom and yet life had a different
plan for me and so I stepped into it
because I thought that that was where I
was called to be and so I think wherever
you're called to be you need to be there
and do that with excellence and the best
and so I hope for my girls they will
realize that anything is possible and
you can do it both you can't have it all
you can't have a family and have a
career it's not always pretty it's not
always pretty it's not always perfect it
doesn't always go smoothly as I write a
lot about in the book going to work with
finding out I've spit up all the way
down my back or you know little
catastrophic baby things but yeah
anything is possible dream big work hard
to pursue it and don't assume it's for
somebody else assume it's for you
that's very true I think we can all hold
onto that and for you as adds at such a
young age you learn to keep up with like
the high speed pace the job is you're
saying you know all these things are
happening and you were able to do it all
what advice do you have for young people
trying to keep up with the demands of a
full-time job while also juggling those
other aspects so
their life yeah it's it's you have to be
very organized you know managing a
household of four little kids I don't
know which is harder running the
president's life we're running that I
mean it truly is a full-time difficult
job I think we need to give ourselves a
lot of grace and cut ourselves a lot of
slack because we expect perfection in
every arena my priority was always the
president's safety first of all I never
wanted anything that I was doing or not
doing to jeopardize obviously his life
or make him look bad jeopardize his
reputation and so I learned to focus on
the things that were most important his
safety his reputation his presence his
persona the smoothness of his day and
then I would say with the same with my
kids you know what are the major
priorities I'm focus on those we can get
upset about every tiny little thing life
isn't always perfect and so don't let
the good don't let the perfect be the
enemy of the good don't expect things to
be perfect but enjoy the good that there
is and the president's life it was it
was challenging because I not only had
to stay pace with him but I had to stay
three steps ahead of him because and
those better be in the right direction
because the president when he would be
in the middle of a meeting he would be
lost in the moment and enjoy in the
meeting and I would take that momentary
snapshot in my head of this amazing
opportunity oh my goodness mother Teresa
who's now is safe I'm here in the room
when observing this but that was one
moment and I'm taking a little snapshot
in my mind and in my mind I'm thinking I
wonder if their lunch is ready
what time is it how do I break this up I
don't want to be rude but I need to get
things moving is you know the gift ready
to present a Secret Service ready to
walk out and so in my mind as I'm
standing there smiling you know taking
pictures or whatever I'm thinking twelve
steps ahead and so I guess that would be
symbolic of your own life you know enjoy
the moment take those snapshots of life
where you are but always be thinking
what's around the corner what's ahead
how can I be ready and prepared my goal
was when the president came to my desk
and said Peggy I'm looking for that I
would literally handed
and he would never have to ask because I
had already anticipated what he would
mean so so after doing a chance to
obviously reflect a lot on the career
that you were able to have with the
president and being able to write the
book is there any kind of advice that
you would wish that's what I've been
able to give you before you had you know
gone through your career that's an
interesting question
you know I in a lot of ways made my own
path my family my dad was a
superintendent of schools he had been a
schoolteacher and went up through the
ranks in the education system my mom
also was a schoolteacher and who went on
to be a college professor and I didn't
really have somebody to look to so I
would say it would be very helpful if
you find somebody who's in your arena if
you find somebody that you think I would
love to do what they're doing or maybe I
just want to know more about what they
do or what that what that arena looks
like talk to them
I find that anybody at any level is
willing to invest in the lives of young
people if they know you have a curiosity
and an interest and are willing to take
their advice and listen to it and take
that into account as you're moving
forward I think it's really helpful to
surround yourself with people and you
may get into a conversation with that
person then think that's not at all what
I'm interested in doing but how great to
find that out now I went into college as
a communications major I had a minor in
business politics was something I always
loved but I saw it more as kind of a
hobby and again just didn't ever think
that it would be so I would be so
fortunate in life to interact with the
political arena at all I never even
imagined that but put a dip a toe into
an arena that you're interested in and
see what that can look like see if you
can picture yourself there see what the
lifestyle is see what the training is
that's required to be there
be bold be bold dream big and work hard
to get there going off of that in your
book you said you had like we gave many
instances where you said yes you know
yes I'll come in for the interview yes I
can start Monday and you know yes that
you can be the primary photographer
those kinds of things and always trying
to make sure you were able to be there
for position and for the president so is
there every time that you remember
saying no and if so why not or why did
you say no well you know I kind of live
by this little motto of where I say I
always say yes when I can and no only
when I have to and I've found that it's
open some interesting doors for me
professionally right now I travel and
speak a lot everything from political
conferences to student conferences to
global executive assistant conferences
but then I've also had some interesting
clients come up and say okay so all the
diplomacy and hospitality stuff you do
can you do that in the sporting world so
I've worked the Final Four and the Super
Bowl and the Kentucky Derby because they
have dignitaries from all around the
world that come and they need somebody
to interface and so just by saying well
sure I think I could do that and in my
mind I'm maybe thinking I don't know if
I can do that but I'll figure it out I
would challenge everybody to say yes
when you can and know only when you have
to it will stretch it will grow you you
will be uncomfortable there's lots of
things I'm uncomfortable doing all the
time still but every time you do that
and you get a success under your belt
you think okay I can I can do that I can
do that so challenge yourself push
yourself and especially when you're
young it's the best time to take a risk
try something new decide you love it or
decide you don't find out what you're
good at and not just the skills and the
things that you're good at but what are
the personality traits that you possess
that are the best of you and even though
your resume may be a little thin
you hard-working are you innovative are
you a great people person
what is it at the core of you that is
the best of you and learn to lead with
that and it will open doors of
conversation and moving forward going
after that passion yeah absolutely and
so the last question I'd like to ask you
before we open it up to questions from
you guys would be for anyone who has
lost someone that they were close to we
know we like certain things around us
that remind us of them so what are some
things that you see that always remind
you of President Reagan yeah you know
it's interesting every time I Drive up
the hill
obviously I I think of him and I think
of being here with him today when I
pulled off the the freeway off-ramp
especially just picturing a year ago
today we brought mrs. Reagan up here and
what an honor it was to be part of
planning her memorial I was actually in
the motorcade that drove her body out
here and I pictured pulling off the
freeway and seeing these policemen
lining up with their motorcycles all in
full dress at full salute and what she
meant in them and what he meant to them
and just the honor of having any
opportunity to be one little part of
their world you know so many people now
are torch bearers for their legacy and
you know are keepers of the flame and
there's so many voices out there and I
feel very privileged to be one of those
moving forward I saw them interacted
them and he's everywhere here I every
time I come to me it's very personal
personal since he's buried here and so I
always make a point every time I'm here
at the library I do always walk by the
graveside as I arrived or when I leave I
hold mr. president I'm still here it's
not talking about you still telling
people how you changed my life and how I
believe your lessons and principles that
you embodied and lived could still
change lives today so yeah he's here
enjoy this place it's a beautiful place
for sure and so now we're going to be
able to open it up to you guys for
questions so I think there are two
microphones going around right here and
if you guys just have a question just go
ahead and raise your hand and
calling you right here in the front oh
good okay my name is Weston Boardman
okay you for speaking with us today
you've had that whole list of traits
that he embody
which trait do you believe in our
society and in our government today are
we missing the most and how can we
rectify that oh that's a really
interesting question I would say this
last political cycle especially I always
say authenticity is something that
people are looking for we've become a
society of soundbites and a reality-tv
that's not really based in reality and
sound bites are not based in substance
and so I think there's this craving for
people that are authentic can you are
you exactly who people think you are
have you created this false persona that
you're really not and so whether people
liked or hated Donald Trump there was an
authenticity about him you knew exactly
what he thought because what he thought
went right through his Twitter feed
right out to all of us and so I think
that that resonated with people and
again whether they loved him or hated
him there was an authenticity to him you
knew what you were getting and I think
there's an appeal to that and I believe
that society's pendulum always swings
and we wind up so far in one direction
that at some point it over corrects and
I think that we are going to be swinging
back towards being the people of
substance and to being a people of a
little bit more authenticity and I think
that we're craving that not just in our
politics but in society good question
West
[Applause]
hello my name is avi savoriness and I
want to thank you again for your very
inspiring perspective on Ronald Reagan's
life I was definitely very inspiring to
me and I'm sure to a lot of other people
as well now my question for you is it
definitely came across that you valued
the values that Ron Reagan stood for but
was it more of the position of authority
as him being President of the United
States that influenced your decision to
see him as a role model or was it more
of your personal beliefs and alignments
of you trying to become more of a
character like he was because you looked
up to him for what he believed in and
what he stood for that influenced more
of what you have become today yeah thank
you very much
I was fairly young I'm Ronald Reagan
took office I was in junior high so I
kind of watched him junior high early
high school of high school and early
college and so as much as I was trying
to follow the politics of things I
wasn't politically savvy I wasn't I
didn't wasn't raised in a home that was
involved in politics and so I was still
trying to figure out my political
ideology and so I would say that that
wasn't even hardly a factor in my
fascination with Ronald Reagan it was
more the way he communicated the way he
made people feel and when you think
about how you communicate with others
they don't necessarily remember every
word you ever say but they will remember
how they felt when you talk to them and
that is far more lasting and so when
Ronald Reagan would talk to me through
the TV camera you know coming through
the lens to my living room there was
this feeling that he was talking right
to me he had a way of connecting to me a
young girl in Southern California and
never imagining I would work for him so
I would say it was the essence of the
man and certainly when he then later
painted a vision
for what we could accomplish as a nation
I was all in because I already had
bought into him as a leader and so it is
it is the character it's the vision and
then I think the policies kind of come
along because we saw a lot of people
cross over vote you know we had
Democrats voting for Ronald Reagan
because they believed in him as a leader
even if they didn't maybe necessarily
align with all the politics and what a
good thing to remember is that we always
have commonalities and a leader should
always be looking for those and
highlighting those rather than the
things that divide us so thank you good
question over here
all right hi I'm Giuliana oh and so I
would say being a part of the Reagan
leadership family now for three years
something big that they've always been
teaching us is how to make the ask how
to like put ourselves out there and
really push for what we want so you said
that you decided you wanted to work in
politics and that your dream job would
be working for President Reagan and you
made that ask by writing that letter so
just how did that feel to be advocating
for yourself and were there like outside
influence that kind influences that kind
of drove you towards advocating for
yourself well I'd like to think that I
was very bold but actually I was so
terrified I did not tell one person that
I wrote the office because I thought
what are the chances I would ever I
didn't tell anybody even I went in for
my interview because I just kept
thinking what are the chances that this
would ever happen and so yeah but I but
I do appreciate that because there had
to have been something in me bold enough
to say maybe there could be a place for
me there maybe there could be a chance
that somebody like me who's not
politically connected who isn't wealthy
and of the donor class maybe there's a
chance that so even somebody like me and
I think for all of you when you're
thinking where is my place
realize that maybe even somebody like
you could step into a place like that
and be prepared for it and be prepared
for that ask you know one of the things
that I think is most important that I
learned in over the years of having to
accomplish things that you think oh how
am I gonna ask this person in front of
this I mean this is crazy what I'm about
to ask them to do for for the president
it's always put yourself in their shoes
so you know what you want to accomplish
but put yourself in their shoes what are
they thinking what is their background
what what are they trying to accomplish
in whatever their business or their
worldview is and so highlight the ways
that what you are asking will benefit
them and that's kind of difficult to do
but if you just pause for a moment and
think about how the other person sees it
you
may put that asked in a very different
way so in my case when I went to the
office I didn't say here's all the great
things that I've done because when you
go in as a college student there's maybe
not that many great things on your
resume they don't care about your grade
point average they don't really care
about you know the little summer jobs
you've had what I did lead with is
here's my traits I am a really hard
worker I'm super disciplined I'm very
thorough and I'm very detail-oriented
oriented I am committed to efficiency
and to excellence these are things that
are hallmarks of every project I've ever
worked on this is the way I live my life
and so when you present yourself in that
way it doesn't really matter what the
resume says my baby said I worked in a
restaurant you know they don't really
that doesn't really apply to the job but
efficiency excellence you're on time
you're hardworking and discipline ok and
go and prepared make sure you've read
the paper that day make sure you know
what's going on Google that company what
what have they been in the news for
recently don't walk in there without
having your game plan ready to go you
can always adjust it but be prepared do
your homework and make sure you're ready
to ask for that opportunity showing how
it will benefit them yeah I tend imagine
making that ask for Gorbachev's hat
trying to figure that size out exactly
make that ask yeah okay we have one more
over here from Otis oh yeah well I I had
another question for you oh well I was
thinking and you mentioned Ronald Reagan
was the Great Communicator we all know
he was able to make that personal bond
with the American people whether it was
through a camera or live speech on stage
but do you believe there are times when
keeping something secret is more
important than communicating it that
whatever value is going to hold even
though you're compelled to share that
idea with the public there's something
that's gonna be keeping you from you
know expressing your idea do you believe
there's ever a circumstance where we
have to remain quiet
rather than being center on the stage
yeah of course of course and especially
a president who is the keeper of all
kinds of secrets you know I I actually
in writing this book had to go through
my own sort of vetting process of for
everything I wrote in the book there's a
thousand things I didn't write and I
wanted to strike that balance between
being revealing so that you felt like
the curtain was being pulled back and
you got to see him in places and
interacting in ways that you ever never
could otherwise see but also having that
ultimate foundation of respect he still
had the right to his privacy and to his
life and just certain things that you
just wait I would never reach that
confidence and so you know part of that
comes with being a leader leaders will
often have more information than they
should share with others and that comes
with maturity and discretion knowing
what people need to know what they don't
need to know and he was a leader not
gloating over people of oh I know more
than you do
but realizing that the importance of
sharing the right information with the
right people in the right way at the
right time and and that's a delicate
balancing act
one that Ronald Reagan I think did
really well the thing that we always
knew that Ronald Reagan had secrets he
couldn't tell us about the thing about
him that I think gave us confidence in
the fact that he had these secrets was
that we knew his heart we knew that he
loved America that he wanted it to be
the best place that could be and that he
had America's best interests in mind and
so when you know the leaders part their
goals their values the core essence of
who they are then the minutiae of the
decisions they make or they little bits
of information here or there they know
or don't know
doesn't really matter so much and that's
why again the leadership component is so
important because the actualities of how
it plays out or the policies or the
exact list of company rules doesn't
matter do you buy into the vision of the
leader and if so that changes everything
we have a question over here hi Shelby
Kaplan
so throughout your entire career with
everything you've done what was the
hardest or most nerve-wracking thing you
had to do and how did you remain
optimistic about it going into it yeah
you know definitely the most
heartbreaking part was when the
president announced that he had
Alzheimer's and that for me personally
was devastating because I had a personal
relationship with him but I would say
even beyond that one of the most
difficult tasks I ever had was being
part of the team that basically released
that information to the world because I
knew how I felt about him and I knew how
millions of people all around the world
felt about him because they would write
to him and they would call him and they
still wanted to be connected to his life
and so here I was one of his biggest
fans one of his biggest supporters and I
was going to be part of shattering his
image of being this invincible super
hero to the world I was going to be part
of that
I dreaded sharing that with the world
because I knew that they would be
devastated and heartbroken and yet I
respected and admired so much his
willingness and ability to put that out
there that was something very private
and very personal you know all the all
the HIPAA laws weren't even in then yet
but it was something that he did not
have to share with the world he and mrs.
Reagan perhaps could have retreated to
the ranch and nobody would have ever
even known but that's not what a public
servant does and he and mrs. Reagan
chose to take something very personal
and private and reveal it in a very
public way so that other people could be
helped and in so many ways we know about
Alzheimer's today because of Ronald and
Nancy Reagan we know what the symptoms
are we know how to better care for
people there's drugs being developed
that will hopefully help alleviate
symptoms all because they were willing
to step into a place of public service
over their need and right to privacy so
I would say that that was a very
challenging time I was very young I was
married I had two little kids
overlapping with that my own father was
dying of colon cancer and so it was a
time I was very I was stretched very
very thin but even that personal grief
wasn't nearly what the guilt kind of I
felt about taking something so awful and
sharing it with the world but that was
what he wanted and so that was what I
would do I think we have time for about
two more questions
now's your chance what
oh we got one more here and one more
there sorry those are two too brave
leaders stepping up I'm so intimidating
I can't tell her hi my name is Emily hi
was it ever difficult for you to follow
through what some of the things that
Ronald Reagan asked for requested let's
just say a lot of that would have been a
lot easier now because of the internet I
mean back in the day I had a word
processor I typed all my envelopes in a
typewriter which you guys probably don't
even know what that is I had a word
processor which I could type letters on
and I could cut and paste and copy but
it wasn't connected to anything there
was no internet and so so much of my job
was spent not only getting information
but trying to figure out how to get
information and so I back in the day I
had a rolodex again dating myself before
it was a database it was actually a
rolodex and you give me five minutes I
could get pretty close to getting
anything you wanted I had contacts at
the White House and at the State
Department and every embassy all around
the world I had you know my little
friends that were here and there and so
a lot of times it was just a matter of
getting on the phone and I'd call and
say hey you got to help me out I'm
trying to get a hold of this person I'm
trying to figure out this piece of
information and a lot of times it was
like a you know down a rabbit trail well
I don't know but I have a friend and if
you call him and say that I told him to
call and tell you no but again the time
change
sometimes I the states in 10 o'clock at
night so I could call overseas and so
there was always a way to get it done
and actually I'm I think I'm glad that
there wasn't the internet back then I
don't know that I would have had a job
maybe they wouldn't need so many people
in the office but at the same time you
really challenged my problem-solving
skills because there always was a way to
get
and there was always a good way to get
it done but it often took a little
creativity a little thought sometimes a
little inconvenience but there always
was a way and so it's kind of how I
approach everything in life now because
I would never turn to the President and
say sorry sir just couldn't figure that
out I would never do that so there was
always a way to figure it out and so
even with your Google search you know be
good problem solvers and think about
what's the best way to get to the best
solution possible I think as leaders we
can all remember that there's always a
way to get there whenever you have an
obstacle yeah and you can do it with a
smile on your face and even for my
shield and then we had one question
where here mm-hmm
good morning everyone I'm cadet first
attendant Guzman so my question is how
did how did you find the way to
communicate effectively with various
leaders you've met yeah so I took my
cues obviously from the president and my
job was always kind of to be behind the
scenes but I like to consider myself
kind of a very visible invisible person
so I kind of had to hover and if the
president ever needed something I wanted
him to be able to turn his eyes and know
that I was there and would jump on
whatever he needed and so just watching
him communicate with people I think that
the thing that impacted me the most
about how we communicated with people is
he always spoke to people and wasn't
above in a preachy way you know preach
in to them and in sermon
it wasn't beneath people or putting
people down he spoke right to people and
it didn't matter whether you were the
head of state or a child visiting the
office you treated everybody with
respect and so I think when your
communication is driven by the other
person again by what's that impression
you want them to have when they leave
and you can look at everybody is just a
person another human and treat them
respectfully look them in the eye like
the president always did I think it sets
up a great platform for a friendship a
working relationship moving forward far
better than worrying about getting the
talking points exactly right how about
connecting with the person the talking
points will take care of themselves
we spent a lot of time these days
especially the political one public
arena working on our talking points but
if we talked to people I don't think
we'll ever go wrong and I know before we
give our huge round of applause I know
she definitely deserves I know she
wanted to share a little bit from her
book to us yeah sorry I read your
passage at the beginning kind of how it
all began and so I thought it would be
appropriate to end with a passage that
is kind of summing up how it all ended
and so I worked for the president for 10
years I like I said I had three of my
four children while I was working there
by the time the president left the
office and wasn't coming into the office
anymore I had three little kids I had
moved quite a distance from the office
and decided it was probably time for me
to go home be home with my kids for a
little bit more time so this is kind of
looking back at the end so it seems
surreal to be leaving for good and yet
looking back on the past ten years it
had all been surreal so maybe this was
just the ending of a very vivid very
realistic and extended dream I thought
back to my first glimpse of the
president as a Pepperdine student and
how exhilarating that was never could I
have imagined how every detail of that
man's face his hands his voice and his
mannerisms would be forever ingrained in
my mind and now in my memory I recalled
the emotions of excitement when I was
invited for my interview and drove up
Avenue of the stars for the very first
time writing in the elevator there
rocketed to the penthouse I thought of
my surprised at how comfortable the
office was from from the outset and how
uncomfortable yet special my first
moment of meeting the president was it
seemed like yesterday when I answered
the phone for the first time office of
Ronald Reagan and now yet ten years
later I had to consciously override that
habit and remember to answer my own home
phone with a simple hello I pictured how
carefree and simple my life was back
then going to the gym dressing for work
commuting traveling socializing and
pouring my whole self into my career
contrast now I sometimes felt like I was
barely staying afloat let alone swimming
along through life with the relative
ease and grace of a few years ago I was
31 years old and I felt like I had lived
10 lives in the past 10 years I had seen
more done more meant more people and
experienced more of life than most
people would in a hundred years I had
gone from feeling Jang and green and out
of place to feeling comfortable
accomplished and confident in my work I
had known what it felt like to be at a
place in my life where the pace and the
people and the productivity thrilled me
brought out the best in me and allowed
me to offer my best to my boss and to my
workplace I knew what it felt like to be
jolted out of bed in the middle of the
night by the 1994 Northridge earthquake
and sure if the house around me would
stand and similarly jolted out of my
comfort zone with the realities of
cancer and Alzheimer's invading my life
and trying to steal the joy from some of
my greatest most memorable and
celebrated years of youth if the
experiences of that all had taught me
that life doesn't happen by accident you
need to prepare and plan and dream and
be ready to grab an opportunity when it
comes your way regardless of how
inadequate you feel for the task at hand
keep trying keep growing keep absorbing
the best in your surroundings and
eventually you too can become
accomplished and become a valued
contributor in an environment that
previously seemed foreign I learned we
all have a greater capacity to work and
multitask and achieve and celebrate and
even mourn simultaneously and we can do
so with a genuine sense of joy and
purpose and contentment even at times in
the midst of sorrow sometimes especially
then I learned that life is truly a
circle and just as I was welcoming new
life I was also reluctantly letting go
of a life that had meant so much to me
and had taught me so much I realized the
gifts we are given seem sometimes to be
unearned
deserve and later are often recalled in
life with the demand that they be
returned in the form of blessing on
others service to others unconditionally
loving others even when their capacity
to reciprocate is gone
I learned that nothing is forever and
had to accept that this amazing chapter
of my life was now ending I mourned its
loss yet was filled with gratitude that
it had ever happened at all thank you
very much for having me here today
[Applause]
Sunday night on afterwords biochemist
sylvia tara looks at the history and
science behind body fat in her book the
secret life of fat she's interviewed by
gina Cullotta
medical reporter for The New York Times
yeah you told us there's a set point
your brain says how much your weight is
what is it changing as you get older
what happens to it yeah so as we age
it's almost a force of nature that we
seem to accumulate more fat at least a
great many of us and you know as we age
we lose hormones we lose a lot of fat
busting hormones that we've had they
decline with age so things like growth
hormone
you know that's helped us rebuild tissue
and helped us grow and kept our fat
metabolizing that declines with age
testosterone levels decline with age and
that's a great fat busting hormone and
both women and men we both have less of
it as we age and this you know so you
can't really eat what you did when you
were 22 that big plate of food you know
it's gonna make you fat as you get older
and it's not just the level of fat it's
the distribution of it that's affected
as well Sunday night at 9 p.m. Eastern
on afterwards
the elite framers people like Madison
Hamilton Washington were a little bit of
ghast that so much democracy had led to
these debt of relief laws and paper
money laws in the mid 1780s and they
wanted to move in the direction of a
government that would be more
constrained more independent of popular
opinion and that actually could shut
down these populist forces in the States
so Madison for example wanted to give
the federal government an absolute veto
over any law passed by a state but that
turned out to be too extreme for the
convention they did write a provision in
article 1 section 10 which bars States
from adopting paper money laws bar
states from passing debtor relief laws
and the idea was with a national
government with very long terms in
office six-year senators 4-year
presidents there was nothing analogous
to that in state constitutions in direct
elections legislatures pick senators the
Electoral College picked the president
enormous constituencies the original
house was 65 members for the entire
country the lower house of the
Massachusetts legislature had over 350
delegates the US Congress had 65 they
thought the larger the constituency the
more likely you would elect the better
sort the elite well-educated relatively
affluent people in the community and
they thought the larger the constituency
the more independence a representative
would have from constituent influence so
in a sense they were profoundly
anti-democratic they wanted to move from
the more democratic state constitutions
in the direction of more elite rule
because they thought that you really
couldn't trust the average person in
government they thought they would
redistribute property they thought
that's what had been happening that's
why Hamilton at the convention favored a
lifetime tenured Senate and a lifetime
tenured president
I mean he's a monarchist basically that
was extreme at the convention but it
wasn't that extreme for delegations at
one point actually vote for voted for a
lifetime tenured president because they
thought property rights wouldn't be
adequately protected in a more
republican form of government
interesting and just did take one one
quick thing you know we're obviously as
is often the case during presidential
election years people often have
questions
about you know how we got the electoral
college can you just take a beat on on
sort of what sort of where that came
from and what was the the framers
rationale for it so they for most of the
convention they thought that the
Congress would pick the president that's
the way most state constitutions worked
as the legislature picked the governor
for most of the convention they had
agreed the president would be selected
by Congress for a single term of seven
years but the problem with a single term
is they thought it would deprive the
president of the best incentive for good
behavior which is the ability to be
reelected the problem with giving the
president the ability to be reelected if
he was picked by Congress is that he
then be very dependent on Congress for
his reelection but the whole point of
having an independent president was to
check Congress they were going to give
the president a veto but if the
president was dependent on Congress for
re-election the president would be leery
about exercising the veto so another
possibility would be direct election by
the people but there were three problems
with that first of all they didn't trust
the people with that important a task
one of my favorite quotes from the
convention is George Mason an important
delegate from Virginia saying that
asking the people to choose the chief
magistrate would be like referring the
choice of colors to a blind man they
didn't trust the people so that's one
problem with direct election a second
problem with direct election is southern
slaves wouldn't count forty percent of
the South's population were slaves they
thought that those slaves oughta count
in terms of increasing the South's
political power in the nation and
finally they thought if you had direct
election the small states would never
have a president this is an era of poor
communication poor transportation and
they weren't assuming the existence of
political parties so they figured people
in large states would just vote for
their candidate if you came from
Massachusetts you'd vote for John
Hancock if you came from Pennsylvania
you vote for James Wilson the small
states would never have a president so
the electoral college system actually
enabled them to compromise lots of
differences one thing is you're not
going to have the president take
directly by the people you're going to
have state legislators deciding how
electors are chosen and then they assume
the electors would exercise in depend
judgment then they apportion the
electoral college in such a way that the
South gets greater clout than they would
in a direct election and the small
states have a greater opportunity to
elect somebody
so the apportion maybe electoral college
as you know is your number of House
members plus your number of senators now
Virginia's by far the largest state it
has twelve times the population of
Delaware in the house there are 10
Virginia representatives one for
Delaware but in the electoral college
you add your senators to your House
members which means they're 12 electors
from Virginia and three from Delaware
that's a four-to-one advantage rather
than a ten to one advantage so the small
states like that
the slave states liked it because their
house numbers includes their number of
slaves through the three-fifths rule and
there's some actually other
complications worked in there now the
only way to defend the electoral college
today the male apportion that first of
all the the indirect election no longer
works that way because now we just have
essentially a popular election to choose
delegates except for the possibility of
the faithless elector but in terms of
the male apportionment basically what
the Electoral College does is it gives
voters in Wyoming four times the power
of voters in California so California
has 55 electoral votes Wyoming has three
that's about an eighteen to one
disparity but California actually has
seventy times the population of Wyoming
and unless you can provide a good
account for why Wyoming voters are
somehow a discriminated against minority
who deserve enhanced power in the
electoral college system there probably
is no good defense for it anymore it
just gives some people inflated power in
choosing the president but the Senate
subject to the same objection and it's
much more extreme so why am moving has
the same two senators as California but
California has seventy times the
population that's just a power play by
the small states in the Philadelphia
Convention they tried to just it was
justify it with fancy philosophical
reasons for why the small states would
be overwhelmed by the large states but
it was basically just a power play and
the small state said we're gonna walk
out of the convention if you don't give
us a quality in the Senate I'm sorry
that was long-winded but it's a
competition
you can watch this and other programs
online at book TV org
book TV tapes hundreds of author
programs throughout the country all year
long here's a look at some of the events
we'll be covering this week on Monday
will be at the Seattle Public Library
with humanities professor Camille Polya
who discusses her essays on gender
equality Wednesday will be at the
Women's National Republican Club in New
York where biographer Craig Shirley will
discuss Ronald Reagan's 1976 and 1980
presidential campaigns Thursday we head
back to the nation's capitol where the
chair of the Museum of American Finance
Richard Silla will discuss the life of
Alexander Hamilton & Hamilton's role in
developing the American banking system
also that evening will be at Harvard Law
School where Fordham Law School
professor John fothe will examine the
causes of mass incarceration on Friday
we're at literati bookstore in Ann Arbor
Michigan where journalist Kevin Davis
will discuss the growing use of
neuroscience in criminal defense cases
also that evening a stop at oblong books
and music and Rhinebeck New York where
former deputy chief of staff to
President Barack Obama Alyssa
Mastromonaco will discuss her
experiences in the White House and
wrapping up the week on Saturday
book TV will be live at the Virginia
festival of the book in Charlottesville
our coverage includes a panel discussion
on nuclear war with authors Susan
Southard Caren stelson and Dan Zak and a
discussion on the media moderated by
White House correspondent April Ryan and
featuring Washington Post senior editor
Mark Fisher and former CNN Washington
bureau chief